grabbing things in space is tricky
unless those things are designed
specifically to fit together it can be a
bit hard to latch on with no atmosphere
suction is out and sticky adhesives are
rendered useless by extreme cold and
degrading radiation so scientists look
to nature for new ideas finding
inspiration in the toes of geckos who
easily scramble up even the smoothest
surfaces the key toes remarkable ability
are microscopic hair strategically
arranged on a geckos feet when pressed
these hairs flatten out against the
surface and tiny forces of molecular
attraction add up across the many points
of contact creating instant grip
scientists try to mimic this technique
by creating tiny wedges that act
similarly to these hairs forces that
smoosh the wedges into a surface create
grip while ten gentle forces peel the
material away by adding this material to
robotic contraptions scientists could
pick up and release objects remotely and
even direct a robot to walk across a
wall scientists tested the grippers on a
minimal friction platform to show that
robots in zero gravity should be able to
grasp objects like solar panels instead
of simply pushing them away
and during the nosedive induced
weightlessness of nasa's famous
zero-gravity aircraft training
astronauts use them to play catch with
both flat and curved objects the
researchers also sent miniature grippers
into space where they stuck to the walls
of the International Space Station
developing such a tool could be
important for many space projects from
clearing out floating debris orbiting
our planet to performing dangerous tasks
with robots
so that astronauts can stay safe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]